di qua eccoci non arrivò in bicicletta
perché sarebbe complicato
come dire portarla su però poi vi
spiegherò di cosa si tratta
per cominciare però voglio fare un
passaggio brevissimo un ringraziamento
ai ragazzi meravigliosi devo mettermi
qui su ai ragazzi meravigliosi che hanno
organizzato questa splendida iniziativa
splendida e io ieri sera ero a cena con
loro e gli chiedevo di spingere queste
iniziative e portarsi oltre perché
abbiamo bisogno di innovare il racconto
di taranto di questa città e questo è un
modo per farlo molto concreto e poi due
passaggi due ringraziamenti io parlerò
sempre al plurale perché io sono stato
sulle nuvole e ci sono un po di persone
che mi hanno portato giù per rendere
concrete le idee perché sulle nuvole si
sogna giusto fabio sulle nuvole si sogna
poi c'è bisogno di tornare qui essere
pesanti
ringrazio la mia famiglia mia moglie che
è un punto fermo e là in fondo cioè
luigi luigi con cui luigi sergi con cui
abbiamo condiviso una parte lunghissima
di questo percorso e spesso ci troviamo
lì a fare i nostri poli e abbiamo
bisogno di essere riportati giu e quindi
parto da qui e cito primo levi perché
perché poi là dentro c'è una spiegazione
importante era veramente idrogeno quindi
lo stesso che brucia nel sole e nelle
stelle e dalla cui condensazione nascono
in eterno silenzio gli universi e una
folgorazione che abbiamo avuto anche
avviando questo progetto e parto
poi pensando alla nostra più grande
fonte di energia il sole e guarda caso
il sole
e fatto di idrogeno fusione scusate agli
astrofisici e se dico corbellerie ma io
sono un po più terra terra nel senso che
l'idrogeno e là dentro e il sole come
abbiamo visto prima e mette questi
fotoni che ci scaldano ci scaldano e
continuano a scaldarci e questo fluido
scorre e incontra l'acqua l'acqua che fa
sale sale però poi non può uscire da
questo sistema perché c'è un una bolla
la bolla che la contiene
e guarda caso lì in alto si formano le
nuvole
beh io facendo questo percorso ho
pensato che le nuvole sono in questo
caso la nostra fonte di ispirazione ma
sono energia in movimento e ho portato
commettere parole acqua energia e ciclo
e immaginerete perché l'acqua è un
elemento essenziale nella nostra
esistenza e in questi momenti stiamo
vivendo che cosa il pericolo della sua
abbondanza recentemente livorno il
pericolo della sua assenza la siccità
gli incendi eppure è un elemento di
grande forza vitale
ecco per noi l'acqua un elemento
centrale in quello che siamo andati a
fare perché l'acqua perché l'acqua in
idrogeno e ossigeno e questi due
elementi la dentro si incontrano ma sono
degli elementi che danno vita
solitamente quando qualcuno mescola un
po di idrogeno gassoso e un po di
ossigeno gassoso non fa qualcosa di
molto sano esplode energia
abbiamo sentito parlare di di come sono
cresciuti per esempio le aspettative di
vita no prima vedevamo che l'acqua la
potabilità dell'acqua ha incrementato la
le aspettative di vita bene nello stesso
periodo che ci faceva vedere la tortora
trattarti dal 1820 al 1000 al 2012 sino
ad oggi abbiamo x 25 i nostri consumi
energetici
ora vuoto per pieno siamo a circa 550
exajoule una cifra mostruosa e
l'evoluzione però è energetica dei
consumi energetici
in realtà ci ha dato stimolo perché se
noi guardiamo la vita dell'uomo e la sua
evoluzione ci siamo resi ci rendiamo
conto che da 120 mila anni fa fino ad
oggi è sempre stata una continua ricerca
di nuove fonti di energia ma le nuove
fonti di energia hanno reso possibile le
evoluzioni e quindi sembra quasi un
ciclo un ciclo che si insegue e va
sempre a crescere tanti più saremo 80
più energia
avremo bisogno di tante più energia
avevano bisogno
e guardate dal 1820 circa sino ad oggi
qual è stata la curva esponenziale della
crescita dei consumi energetici e questo
ha reso inevitabile la ricerca di nuove
fonti di energia
ora sentiamo parlare di fotovoltaico
sentiamo parlare di eolico ma la prima
pala eolica nasce nel 1930 il primo
impianto fotovoltaico nel 1954 non
secoli fa decenni fa bene questo è un
elemento che dobbiamo considerare è che
sembra un fil rouge che sta seguendo un
po tutti i tutti i nostri interventi
la crescita alla crescita alla crescita
e il ciclo il ciclo per noi è un metodo
un metodo che può avere periodi lunghi o
brevi ma ecco io ho parlato dell'acqua
la prima cosa che si insegna in una
scuola elementare bambini e il ciclo
dell'acqua questa acqua che viene
scaldata dal sole che sale poi ritorna
giù come pioggia e riempie i fiumi
riempi i laghi riempie i mari bene
il ciclo per noi è un elemento
determinante in questo modello che ora
vi presenterò ecco da qui nasce a idro
krasì hydro casi per noi o un nuovo
paradigma è un nuovo paradigma che serve
per sopperire ai crescenti fabbisogni
energetici ma serve per sopperire anche
la domanda esistente di energia
noi possiamo cambiare le modalità di
produrre energia di consumare energia
non solo efficientando quello che
abbiamo ma producendo energia pulita e
tutto questo grazie alle tre parole che
vi ho rappresentato prima e sono l'acqua
perché il nostro sito si basa
esattamente sulle elettrolisi dell'acqua
ciclo perché vedrete che abbiamo chiuso
un ciclo in cui l'energia non esce se
non per la minima parte e energia
e tutto questo noi lo possiamo applicare
a vari settori e ora vi mostrerò cosa
abbiamo fatto
lo possiamo applicare a vari settori e
tutto a emissioni zero è possibile una
strada possibile e allora ci siamo
inventati una cosa si chiama smartbox è
un nome banalissimo ve lo posso
garantire
smartbox clicchiamo e ne vengono fuori
milioni però questa si chiama smart box
perché è una scatola intelligente ed è
una scatola intelligente che fa fa
esattamente una roba di questo genere
immaginiamo di avere una bella casa con
sopra il suo impianto fotovoltaico e nel
momento in cui non consumiamo l'energia
ma l'impianto produce invece di buttarla
cela conserviamo trasformandola in
idrogeno
dopodiché quando l'impianto fotovoltaico
non funzionerà più perché è buio
noi metteremo in moto una fuel cell una
cella a combustibile che converte
l'idrogeno in energia elettrica e
abbiamo sopperito al fabbisogno
energetico nel
no periodo di vita di una casa ed è
questo il ciclo
noi abbiamo un prosumer ci piace
chiamarli non più consumatori ma
prosumer perché perché mettiamo in moto
e un'economia di scambio
il produttore che diventa consumatore e
scambia energia ma sotto forma di
idrogeno non più sotto forma di energia
elettrica e vi spiegherò anche perché il
prosumer che viene alimentato dalle
fonti rinnovabili
quel ciclo di cui vi ho detto viene
gestito dalla nostra smartbox e quindi
l'energia non esce mai da questo ciclo
ma rimane là dentro
e questo quello che avete visto non è un
ciclo teorico un ciclo che noi abbiamo
realizzato qui a taranto
realizzato in un sito industriale nel
sito industriale di gomez e ora questo
ciclo è questa smartbox sono in funzione
nel nostro impianto industriale e serve
per alimentare totalmente una stecca di
uffici che ora sono sostenuti solo dalle
fonti rinnovabili e dal ciclo idrogeno
uno si domanda vabbè ma non potete alla
stessa cosa con le batterie sì però poi
vi faccio vedere abbiamo pensato quindi
che questo progetto possa ricadere molto
bene in due ambiti molto interessanti
per quanto ci riguarda le aree rurali
remote che ora per lo più sono servite
da gasolio
quindi sostituendo totalmente le
emissioni di gas climalteranti con fonti
rinnovabili e con il sostegno dell
idrogeno di questo questo power bank
chiamiamolo così a idrogeno e nelle
isole
ora pochi sapranno ma fortunamente anche
il governo italiano ha deciso di
investire denari su due progetti per le
isole minori
le isole minori sono sotto l'attenzione
del governo italiano perché sono
elemento in cui la generazione elettrica
che un fabbisogno
si consuma bruciando gasolio e quindi le
nostre fattorie oi nostri le nostre
isole possono diventare benissimo un
luogo di scambio e di condivisione
sharing economy quante volte abbiamo
parlato sentito parlare di questa
modalità di scambio di collaborazione la
cooperazione la cooperazione in per noi
è importante ecco perché prosumer non
perché uno è consumatore e produttore
per sé il profumo e collabora per
definizione e quindi entra anche ora una
volta nella rete entra nella rete
scambiando scambiando cosa scambiando
energia e ecco perché l'idrogeno e non
le batterie perché l'idrogeno e
versatile noi abbiamo idrogeno per
alimentare immaginate una fattoria per
alimentare i trattori a fuel cell
quindi si elimina la fabbisogno di
gasolio per l'attrazione i trattori e
per il sostentamento dell'economia
rurale si possono alimentare le auto a
idrogeno e si possono alimentare anche
le bici a idrogeno
questa è una bicicletta è un gioco che
abbiamo voluto mettere insieme ma in
realtà è molto più di un gioco e un
gioco concreto la nostra idea è che una
bici elettrica e una bici a pedalata
assistita sia una grande conquista per
la mobilità delle persone soprattutto
nelle aree urbane bene la nostra
intenzione è aumentare la percorrenza e
lo abbiamo fatto abbiamo triplicato la
percorrenza di una bicicletta entry
level nata la abbiamo triplicato la
percorrenza
con la pedalata assistita e questo e
grazie all'idrogeno che noi produciamo
nel nostro sito e che ci ricarica una
bombola bomboletta che sta lì dietro e
alimenta tutto il sistema per tenere in
carica la nostra batteria certo peserà
ora pesa un po di più ma il nostro la
nostra idea di far diventare quello un
oggetto interessante di design leggero e
che possa essere applicato a una
molteplicità di bici a pedalata
assistita
ecco perché l'idrogeno perché questo con
le batterie non lo avremmo potuto fare e
finiscono finisco con una piccola
notazione greening the unders e di
industries
bene noi viviamo un grande conflitto qui
a taranto
noi possiamo lanciare un segnale molto
forte
possiamo lanciare del segnale per cui è
possibile rendere più compatibile le
presenze inquinanti che emettono grazie
all'uso della di fonti rinnovabili e di
idrogeno
perché noi produciamo idrogeno solo da
fonti rinnovabili ed è questa la chiave
di volta non facciamo reforming di
metano perché chi sa i grandi produttori
di idrogeno producono dal reforming del
metano
e mentre noi utilizziamo solamente fonti
rinnovabili
bene questo ciclo energetico vive qui a
taranto e ora siamo pronti per
esportarlo speriamo nel mondo e grazie
per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]